what
where am i boom
got it nailed it where am i what's going
on i get bored up here man same thing
all day every day thought i'd mix it up
and try and predict what you're gonna
say so far one for one i didn't get the
what but you know it's implied what in
parentheses where am i one for one
i'm dead two for two
you're dead people have a hard time with
that one but if you look around it's
pretty obvious
this
can't be real yeah i know it looks a
little green screen but we really are at
the gates of heaven
man i'm good i know all saints are good
but i'm very good at this that brings us
to i have to go back yes my pornography
is everywhere
i oh god
i have to go back and hide my
pornography okay
a bit of a curveball i didn't get the
pornography part but i i think we can
turn it around
there was so much pornography
i died in a room surrounded by
pornography
they cannot find me in a room with so
much pornography
hey
hey we were doing good maybe maybe take
it off the whole pornography tip and uh
there was so much more i wanted to do
there you go
i never got to see the end of ass
assassinator 2.
oh um little order mix up but i got you
never got to see the end of ass
assassinator 2.
wow you are good at the end he
assassinates all the asses but don't
worry they have it in there oh there's a
lending library
oh thank you you're welcome thank you so
much jesus not
not jesus
you